[Música]
el reloj que está moviéndose para las
campañas de donald trump y fire en el
segundo debate tendrá como temáticas la
lucha contra el coronavirus el cambio
climático el racismo la seguridad
nacional el liderazgo y la familia el
jefe de campaña de donald trump había
asegurado que este último cara a cara se
había centrado en la política exterior
sin embargo la comisión no lo planteó
mientras tanto este lunes después de un
mitin en el estado clave de arizona el
presidente camps dejó claro que quiere
pasar la página de la pandemia y que los
estadounidenses están cansados de la
crisis y que los ciudadanos no quieren
hablar más del cob y 19a lo que piden
respondió señor presidente usted tiene
razón en un aspecto los estadounidenses
están cansados están cansados de sus
mentiras sobre este virus están cansados
de ver más muertes y de ver que más
personas pierden sus trabajos porque
usted se rehúsa a tomar esta pandemia de
forma seria entretanto la comisión de
debates presidenciales ha hecho cambios
a la normatividad del último debate
programado para este jueves y ha
anunciado que los micrófonos de los
candidatos serán mute a dos durante dos
minutos al inicio de cada tramo para
evitar interrupciones las citas
y último debate será en nashville
tennessee y ambos candidatos han
reafirmado su acuerdo con la regla de
los dos minutos sin interrupciones según
el comunicado de la comisión de debates
[Música]